[موسيقى]
ه اطفال شهداء اطفال اثر قصف اسرائيلي
يعني طفله وطفل اثر قصف اسرائيلي وضابط
اسعاف اثر قصف اسرائيلي لمحطه الاسعاف
التابعه لوزاره الصحه قرب ملعب فلسطين حتى
هذه اللحظه عدد من الاصابات وثلاثه شهداء
وصلوا تفاجانا باطلاق الصواريخ على محطه
الاسعاف وقدا في الدبابات بدون سابق انظار
والاش رمي على الارض شهداء سائقين الاسعاف
واولاد صغار من
النازحين
ها كنا في المحطه المركزيه للاسعاف ضربوا
اول قزيفه
مقابل المحطه البوابه الرئيسيه نزلت في
ضربه سمرا احنا خلينا شويه لتحت شويه برض
ضربوا الزيفه جنب ملعب فلسطين كمان قزيفه
القذيفه الثالثه نزلت علينا في المحطه
نفسها عند
مخازن الادويه الحمد لله جبتوا البنت
مستشهد البنت ورفيق